when you were talking about going to
Mets games as a boy I thought wouldn't
it be nice if your dad flew into town
for the big day oh yeah I don't think so
why not
didn't you hear the double-o the comedy
legend Gary Marshall who was playing my
father in this episode which was really
exciting
hello son I am the new Odd Couple which
is terrific
we have Garry Marshall on the show
finally by the way and Oscar's gonna
throw out a pitcher to Mets game and
Felix thinks wouldn't it be great if his
father came to see him throughout his
pitch to the Mets game look it's my dad
you sent me a ticket and then uber and
Oscars very mad at Felix for doing that
was I at a presumption was inviting him
here without your permission
perhaps did I miss calculate the level
of your estrangement apparently am I
gonna kick your ass if you keep talking
this way absolutely and that's how it
all strengths thing asked his father I
guess I'm the right age now you know it
moves along I acted a little on the old
God by him play anybody my only request
was to have a scene with him and I
threatened to quit if I did not hi I'm
Danny I work with your son hi there
gorgeous suite are you sure he's your
dad you know they have that father-son
thing happening where he's constantly
seeking his father's approval and Gary's
such a lovable guy that everybody else
in the cast loves him and that really
frustrates Oscar maybe you two should
talk you have this precious time and
you'd spend it all in front of your
Bluetooth and you turn it up
it's getting a little chatty in here we
talk about sports and actually get close
a certain amount of warmth for me
certainly I was raised by all of his TV
shows and
don't tell my parents this but I was
never happier than to be left home with
a babysitter and a Salisbury steak
frozen dinner and watching happy two
hits and Laverne and Shirley and Mork
and Mindy and everything that has come
out of his mind so it is equal parts
intimidating and amazing all at the same
time and he's also just like everybody's
sweet grandpa it's a grandpa you wish
you have